uganda en alerta máxima un mes después
de que el país de África Oriental
declarara un rebrote de Hola Ya se
reportan 64 casos confirmados y 24
muertos a causa de la enfermedad
contagiosa las autoridades sanitarias
locales han restringido el movimiento en
los distritos de movent y Casandra los
más afectados por el rebrote
tenemos unos tres objetivos Uno de ellos
es asegurarnos de no tener ningún
contacto que se mude fuera de estos
distritos a otras partes del país que
son principalmente las áreas donde
tenemos los casos y quiero creer que
hasta ahora ustedes no nos han oído
hablar de ningún caso nuevo proveniente
de otros lugares
las autoridades temen que haya un súper
registro en las cifras ya que la zona
Rurales son las más afectadas el ébola
se transmite por fluidos corporales
causando fiebre vómitos y en ocasiones
hemorragias hasta causar la muerte las
personas infectadas se vuelven
contagiosas entre los dos y los 21 días
luego de aparecer los síntomas los
países de África occidental son
propensos a los brotes de ébola el
último mató a más de 11.000 personas
entre 2014 y 2016 afectando fuertemente
a uganda la Organización Mundial de la
Salud ha expresado su preocupación
frente a este último rebrote
seguimos preocupados de que pueda haber
más cadenas de transmisión y más
contactos de los que conocemos en las
comunidades afectadas el Ministerio de
salud está investigando los ocho casos
más recientes ya que los informes
iniciales indican que no se encontraban
entre los contactos conocidos
actualmente no existe una vacuna contra
esta cepa del ébola sin embargo la
Organización Mundial de la Salud anunció
que iniciará ensayos clínicos de vacunas
Durante las próximas semanas en uganda